contraction post mortem des ligaments
postérieurs du coup mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire que ce charabia et bien
tout simplement ça désigne ce repli de
la tête vers la queue et de la queue
vers la tête qu'on voit sur le
velociraptor à l'image quand eli sattler
prononce cette phrase alors se replie de
la tête vers la queue il est dû à une
contraction après la mort donc
contraction post mortem des muscles et
non pas des ligaments des muscles de la
colonne vertébrale et ses muscles de la
colonne vertébrale en se contractant et
bien ils vont replié le corps la tête
vers là que la queue vers la tête et
c'est pour ça que souvent les
velociraptor et même les théropodes
qu'on retrouve fossilisés les squelettes
entiers qu'on retrouve fossilisés très
souvent ils ont la tête qui est replié
vers le dos ouvert là que parce que
justement il ya une contraction post
mortem de ses ligaments
c'est pas typique aux dinosaures on les
retrouve chez les oiseaux mais c'est pas
typique seulement oklad des dinosaures
on retrouve ça aussi à l'extérieur des
dinosaures chez des mammifères par
exemple est ce qu'il y à un intéressant
c'est qu'en prononçant cette phrase est
bien elle la termine par velociraptor
contraction post mortem des ligaments
postérieurs du coup velociraptor point
d'interrogation
alors non c'est pas typique aux
velociraptor cette contraction post
mortem des ligaments du coup enfin des
muscles du cou comme je le disais on
retrouve sache et plein d'autres
vertébrés notamment des mammifères et on
retrouve ça par exemple chez les
sauropodes c'est l'image que je vous
affiche en ce moment à l'écran donc un
bon gros dinosaures à long cou je crois
que c'est un camarasaurus et ce
camarasaurus vous pouvez voir qu'il
allait la tête repliaient vers l'arrière
exactement comme havel aussi raptor peut
être moins prononcé que sur le l'image
du film mais c'est le même concept
alors cette scène elle est intéressante
pas seulement pour la contraction des
muscles postérieurs du coup mais aussi
pour tout un tas d'autres phrases
relativement technique donc assez
surprenant à voir dans un film grand
public comme ça c'est des phrases qui
sont très techniques mais qui ont toutes
un véritable lien avec la paléontologie
donc c'est là qu'on voit qui a eu un
paléontologue dans le processus
d'écriture donc jacques corner qui a été
inclus
comme consultant sur le film jurassic
park parce que ceux qui le disent après
eh bien ça a du sens paléontologique
mans donc notamment pour le professeur
grande se penche vers l'écran et il dit
ceci
regardez ces petits sauts en demi-lune
cette attache c'est pas étonnant que ces
loustics est appris à voler alors c'est
petit zoo en demi lune qu'ils désignent
et bien ce sont les aux semis lunaire ce
sont des os du poignet d'ailleurs vous
noterez qu'il montre les pattes arrière
sur le film et non pas les os du poignet
mais bon on va dire que voilà c'était
pas c'était pas facile à montrer mais
bref les eaux en demi lune dont il parle
ce sont les os du poignet qui s'appelle
les semis lunaire et ce sont les petits
os du poignet qui permettent aux
dinosaures quand vous voyez souvent dans
les documentaires de replier leurs
poignets lelong enfin de replier leurs
mains le long de leur avant bras
c'est un mouvement qui est complètement
pas naturel pour nous mais qui est
naturel pour les théropodes et les
oiseaux du moins pour les théropodes
maniera pto rien et les oiseaux qui
possèdent cette hausse semi lunaire
cette hausse semi lunaire c'est la
fusion de quelques os du poignet qui
permettent ce mouvement de repli des
mains le long des avant bras
donc ça c'est petit zoo ils sont
effectivement présents chez velociraptor
et seo effectivement faisant partie de
la main font partie du processus de vol
chez les oiseaux donc ce qu'il dit là en
fait ça a complètement du sens
paléontologique mans même si ce qu'il
montre à l'image en fait ce sont les
pieds et pas les mains ensuite il
enchaîne par peut-être que les
dinosaures en plus en commun avec les
oiseaux qu'avec les reptiles et ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'était déjà vrai à
l'époque donc c'est pas avant gardiste
non plus mais à l'époque il faut bien
savoir qu'on avait encore trouvé aucun
dinosaures à plumes en chine il n'y
avait jamais eu de dinosaures à plumes
découvert à l'époque à part archéoptéryx
mais qui était considéré comme un oiseau
donc c'était presque normal de trouver
des plumes chez lui quoi donc il y avait
aucun dinosaures à plumes à l'époque
donc balancer comme ça sur un film grand
public
une théorie encore relativement
controversé qu'est celle de des oiseaux
descendants des dinosaures
c'est quand même assez osée et donc
après il enchaîne en parlant regarder
cette hausse pubiens a tourné vers
l'arrière comme un oiseau donc ça c'est
vrai le l'os pubien de velociraptor
il n'est pas tournée vers l'avant donc
l'os pubien c'est le pubis sais ce que
c'est le losc qui lie à l'avant du
bassin et donc il y a deux grands clad
chez les dinosaures celui d or need is
la grande famille des ornithischiens les
dinosaures herbivores et la famille des
sceaux risque ya les dinosaures
carnivores qui sont distingués par la
morphologie de leur bassin donc je vais
essayer de faire ça simple mais en gros
les oiseaux sont descendants des
dinosaures à bassin dit de reptiles donc
les sort ischia et chez les souris se
tient le pubis est orienté vers l'avant
et chez les oiseaux le public s'est
orienté vers l'arrière et en fait
velociraptor il est intermédiaire entre
les deux dans le sens où son pubis et
bien il est orienté vers le bas il est
né vers l'avant ni vers l'arrière il
émigre est à mi-chemin donc là ce qu'il
est en train de montrer à ce moment là
le pubis tourner vers l'arrière comme un
oiseau en fait il est à moitié migrer
vers l'arrière presque comme un oiseau
donc ça c'est un caractère qui est très
intéressant et qui est pointée du doigt
dans jurassic park et après il désigne
les vertèbres plein de poches d'air et
de cavités comme un oiseau à l'arche et
le velociraptor les vertèbres sont pas
pleines de cavités mais elles en ont
quelques unes et il ya effectivement la
cavité dit pleut rosell c'est à dire la
cavité qui se trouve sur le côté des
vertèbres et qui est présente chez tous
les théropodes au moins les plus dérivés
donc velociraptor par exemple
tyrannosaurus cela ils ont des vertèbres
qui ont des cavités et qui sont
relativement pneumatiques c'est à dire
qu'ils sont plus ou moins remplis d'air
et chez les oiseaux on a les mêmes
qualités en beaucoup plus développée en
beaucoup plus nombreuses et qui sont
aussi plein d'air pourquoi parce
qu'elles sont connectés au poumon
donc chez les oiseaux vous avez en fait
les poumons qui ont des petits des
petites ramifications qui se développe
et qui remplissent les vertèbres d'air
et ça allège le corps de l'animal en
tout cas jurassic park a raison de
pointer du doigt le fait que ces cavités
pleuraux sel sont en commun entre
velociraptor et les oiseaux et jurassic
park avait même poussé le vice beaucoup
plus loin en nous parlant de lomé au
termine donc lomé au ter me c'est la
capacité de maintenir son corps à la
même température donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on connecte bien souvent au
fait d'avoir le sang chaud et vaut
savoir qu'en 1993 on n'a pas tellement
de raison de penser que les dinosaures
avaient le sang chaud je vous rappelle
encore une fois qu'on n'avait pas de
dinosaures à plumes les plumes ça permet
de faire une couche isolante qui permet
de garder la chaleur à l'intérieur mais
si on pensait à l'époque que les
dinosaures n'avait pas de plumes
il n'y a pas de raison qu'il soit à sang
chaud
donc à l'époque en 93 c'était quand même
assez innovant de par les dom et aux
termites donc de capacité à garder la
température de son corps au même niveau
chez les dinosaures et il en parle dans
jurassic park donc la scène où le petit
raptor est clos et il demande à quelle
température ils sont le professeur roux
répond 32° 7 et sattler répond homéo
termine avec un point d'interrogation et
la docteur roux hoche la tête donc aux
hommes et aux termites oui et c'est là
qu'on se rend compte que jurassic park à
l'époque il était vraiment à la pointe
des connaissances scientifiques voire
même légèrement avant gardiste après on
pourrait plutôt contesté que les oiseaux
sont à 41 degrés plus qu'à 32 degrés les
oiseaux sont très très chaud mais bon
après on est sur des dinosaures donc il
pourrait être intermédiaire entre la
condition reptilienne est la condition à
vienne 32° 7 c'est quand même plutôt une
température de reptiles donc cette scène
avec le velociraptor à l'écran c'est
vraiment une petite pépite pour les
paléontologues d'aujourd'hui parce que
c'était vraiment à la pointe des
théories les plus subversives qu'on
avait à l'époque
alors évidemment elle n'est pas dénuée
de petites erreurs et notamment le
velociraptor bon je vais pas redire
encore une fois que velociraptor de
jurassic park c'est en fait des nonick
us dans la vraie vie sains comme il le
dit à m 82 aux deux mètres 80 de long ce
sont les mensurations de dénis q ce
qu'il décrit là et pas celle de
velociraptor qui était beaucoup plus
petit par contre ce qui a vraiment
dommageable dans le film c'est
velociraptor mongolienne si ce qu'on
trouve dans le montana
je répète velociraptor mongolienne si ce
qu'on découvre dans le montana
il n'y avait pas de velociraptor du tout
en amérique du nord n'y en a jamais eu
il y avait des cousins de velociraptor
comme le démonique us mais il n'y avait
pas de velociraptor même velociraptor
n'a vécu camps nazis
donc maintenant on peut repenser à la
scène où john amende débouche la
bouteille de champagne et ou grant
l'interrompt en disant ah on l'avait
mise de côté
ah bah oui on l'avait mise de côté oui
pour une grande découverte comme la
découverte d'un vélociraptor en amérique
du nord
donc il a raison de lui répondre pour
aujourd'hui pour aujourd'hui ça je peux
vous l'assurer
[Musique]